im oberbayerischen traunstein baut der
freistaat für den bund diesen steg für
fußgänger und radler aber mit der
schicken neuen brücke gibt es ein
heftiges problem denn bei der montage
der stahlelemente hat man festgestellt
sie passen nicht zusammen die 1,9
millionen euro teure brücke hat deshalb
eine lücke und ist seit monaten gesperrt
die menschen den traunstein schlagen die
hände über dem kopf zusammen
es ist wirklich einfach weil es dort
übergibt mit dem anspruchsvollen bauwerk
gibt es von anfang an probleme erst
wollen anwohner den heilig geist steht
gerichtlich verhindern
als dann nach jahrelangen planungen
mitte 2018 die bauarbeiten endlich
beginnen ist schnell klar
die brücke wird nicht wie geplant im
märz 2019 fertig werden im sommer wird
in einer aufwendigen aktion das zweite
brückenelement eingesetzt wenigstens zum
schuljahresbeginn soll der beheizbaren
steg fertig werden
doch bei der montage gibt es die böse
überraschung die teile passen nicht
zusammen können nicht verschweißt werden
sie klappen um mehrere zentimeter
auseinander
ich finde es reichlich peinlich das muss
man sagen weil wir bauen jetzt schon
polare brücken und es ist schon traurig
dass man auf diesen langen planungs und
bauphase jetzt das eigentlich eine
fertig bringt das ist nicht akzeptabel
für uns anwohner und für alle die ja
eigentlich die straße kehren müssen
das staatliche bauamt traunstein weiß
die verantwortung weit von sich
in mehreren gutachten will die behörde
klären wie es zu dem fehler kommen
konnte
fertigungs oder planungsfehler
schriftlich heißt es es liegt nahe dass
die mars abweichungen bei der fertigung
im werk erfolgten aber auch eine
unerwartete verformung der gesamten
konstruktion oder teile davon
aufgrund noch nicht identifizierte
einflüsse ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass
niemand den fehler rechtzeitig entdeckt
hat nach all den jahren planung kann im
traunstein kann
glauben bei so viel steuergeldern wieder
rein gesteckt werden sollten
verschiedene kontrollinstanzen
eigentlich mehrmals über die arbeit
darüber gucken ich habe angst dass es
gutachten über gutachten gibt und sich
vielleicht doch noch jahre hinziehen
in traunstein suchen sie nach einer
lösung um die brücke zu retten
ob das klappt kann derzeit niemand sagen
schlimmstenfalls muss der heiliggeist
stieg komplett zurückgebaut werden wir
am ende auf den kosten sitzen bleibt
muss ebenfalls noch geklärt werden